and joining us now with more on the
illegal immigrant Mass shooter taken
into custody is Fox News contributor Ted
Williams is back with us Ted great to
see you thank you
um what's so frustrating I was beginning
to get very concerned that this guy
probably went back to Mexico and that
meant that the likelihood we would ever
get him would be very low
um I'm glad that didn't happen but the
problem here Ted is that this guy was
deported on five separate occasions that
means our border is that wide open when
you're talking about as of now since Joe
Biden being president six and a half
million illegal immigrants have entered
this country and it's about to get
dramatically worse with the end of title
42 they are not prepared for what's
about to come and all of it was under
control When Donald Trump was president
I mentioned well Sean I got to tell you
uh you're absolutely right uh we're here
on the scene where the state local and
the federal officials are going to hold
a press conference to announce the
capture of Francisco arapesa or aeroposa
was uh the is the suspect in the killing
of five uh individuals his neighbors
Sean you said something that just shocks
the conscience and that is that this man
had been deported at least on five
different occasions the last occasion
was in 2016 and here from 2016 to the
current time period he's been here
living in the United States uh and no
one has done anything about him and it
was on Friday night
that he was shooting a gun in his yard
that his neighbor came over and asked
him to stop shooting because they had a
baby in the house he then left his home
went next door to his neighbor's house
shot his neighbors five people in that
home and then took off and he's been on
the run and one of the things that
you've said that I am elated about is
that they've captured him and they've
captured him in the United States
because if he would have made it to
Mexico let's say and uh he would have
been over there and they wanted to
charge him let's say in Texas with
capital murder of these five individuals
Mexico would not have extradited him
back to this country also this illegal
alien is now off the street from what
we've been told we're waiting for the
press conference it's unbelievable
that's how porous that's how wide open
our borders are it is all preventable
and that's the saddest part of all of
this five innocent people dead
um and at least he's in custody uh we
expect that press conference any minute
now when that happens we will bring that
to you uh Ted Williams stay there we'll
come back to you uh throughout the hour
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else